you can relax are you everybody feel
okay
come on come on come on come on come on
come on if you want to cultivate the
land in south africa
say these farmers
this is the sort of training
a two-week tactical survival course run
by a former member
of the israeli special forces
is teaching this group how to ward off
or neutralize the enemy
a self-described practical guide to
staying alive
they're here because they want to make a
difference
they want to they want to defend their
life to feel more secure for
for the family and for them
nice nice nice and his pupils claim
plenty of real world experience
i've been attacked myself and these
attackers
they were trying to play very well
so and i got shot in my face and i
you can see the marks over there and i
got stabbed
nine times by a knife but i survived it
it's personal accounts like these that
fuel the sense of fear
and people like marley swanepool think
they're being targeted
because they're white
and i get very emotional about it
what what is happening in south africa
um
our people are getting murdered tortured
where is old people who everyone defend
themselves or being
burned with
cooking oil the number's just raising
by the day it's raising but i mean you
are always worried that you will be the
next
crime stalks the lives of all south
africans
but farmers feel particularly vulnerable
74 were killed last year
according to official statistics
although many think the true picture
is worse those pharma takes are brutal
and usually they don't steal anything so
there's something we don't know what it
is
but they are just getting murdered and
then they leave
[Music]
but blacks are also victims of brutal
crimes
two white farmers tried to seal this 20
year old into a coffin
the farmers were convicted of attempted
murder last year
crime happens to everyone it's
criminality that is happening in the
farms
and we have always condemned it but this
crime does not only happen to white
farmers it also happened to black farm
workers
the case lit a fuse and drew large
protests at
court white farmers own vast tracts of
land in south africa
and receive little sympathy the right
people's culture of life in these
countries at the tires they live
a world a first wealth lifestyle in a
third world country
and the majority of the population lives
a third-world
lifestyle in a third-world country so
and that majority is the blacks
so the ruling anc is taking drastic
action
they've adopted a new policy called land
expropriation
without compensation
a decision that deeply worries people
like philip pottita
he's a fourth generation farmer in the
hills of limpopo
it's worrying because promises are being
made to the masses
and you don't want to make promises to
the masses and
not deliver so currently
it's it's a boiling pot we grew year by
year mr pothita
took us for a tour of his avocado and
nut farm
it's a profitable business employing
hundreds of local people
and he's not prepared to hand it over
it's in our blood
our ancestors our fathers grandfathers
this is what we were born to do i mean
where do i go
i kind of just pack up here and leave
everything we've done here
this farm is already subject to four
claims
filed by community groups who say the
land originally belonged to them
and the official overseeing the process
says mr pothita
will have to come to the table what do
you say to a guy who owns land that's
been in the family for four or five
generations
there's nothing we can do but we can put
you through the process together with
the community
until we find a way out of this because
it
needs to happen so if it needs to happen
you cannot say
you cannot clean my length no you cannot
say that
what you can say it has to happen
the government says land will be
redistributed
because the stability of the nation
depends on it
but it may be a long and violent journey
john sparks sky news in limpopo